-Hello, Cynthia.
How are you?
-I'm good, Seth.
-I'm wonderful.
It's always good to see you.
I want to ask, you know,
I'm coming up
on about 20 years
of being a New Yorker.
You've lived here
your whole life.
Has this time --
Has this difficult time
reminded you of other eras
of upheaval in the city?
-I mean, New York, yeah.
I've been living here
since I was born in 1966.
Our city goes through a lo
of crises from time to time.
And I have to say, yes,
it's been really reminding m
of the early days of
the AIDS crisis, you know?
I feel like the same way
Black Lives Matter protester
have taken to the streets
and are completely
changing our world,
I feel like that is what
AIDS activists did,
what LGBT people did,
founding ACT UP,
taking to the streets,
disrupting traffic.
And because, similarly,
you know,
there was an epidemic going on
in their community
that the rest of the world
seemed basically unaware of,
and in order to seize
the world's attention
and demand an enormous change,
that's what LGBT people
did then.
And that's what, you know,
so many Black Lives Matter
protesters are doing now.
And I have to say,
when Trump was elected,
I was so inspired
by the women's marches
not only in this country,
but across the world.
But I think now the estimate i
something like 20 million Blac
Lives Matter people have -
protesters have, across
the country, participated.
And we've never seen a movemen
like that in this country --
every race of person,
every ethnicity,
every age, every gender.
-You know, I think when yo
talk about these movements
that demand enormous change,
one of the most important things
is just to educate, right?
Like, people aren't fully aware.
And I think that, you know
what you've seen
with just the last five year
of how Black Lives Matter
is perceived as a movement
a lot more people
obviously think of it
in a more positive way
as a necessary movement.
And I think that's also true
in politics.
Last time you were here,
you were running
on a progressive agenda,
you know, for governor.
And while you didn't win,
it does seem that a lot
of what was maybe framed
as a little bit more left,
a little more, you know,
out of the mainstream
has now been pulled into favor
Do you feel happy about the fact
that, you know,
while you did not, you know,
obviously win the election
it does feel like
a lot of your ideas
are now viewed
a lot more favorably?
-Yes. I mean, I was --
2018, there was an incredibl
blue wave in New York Stat
that is continuing.
And we took the New York State
Senate back for the Democrats.
And we've been able to --
in just a couple of years,
we've been able to pass th
Green New Deal for New York.
We've done major bail reform
We've had driver's license
extended to everyone,
including undocumented people.
We've updated our abortion laws.
We've passed the
Gender Expression
Nondiscrimination Act.
It just goes on and on and on.
And one of the exciting things
is that we're actually two votes
away from a veto-proof majorit
in the New York State Senate
And so when that happens,
God willing, very soon,
we will no longer have to
be dependent on the governor
for passing
all the progressive things
that we want to have
in New York State and can have
-You have been critical of bot
the governor and the mayor
in their handling, particularl
the early days of the pandemic
But you wrote an op-ed
that you had a unique angle on
because you are both in sort o
the TV film production
that is so vital to the city
as well as being a parent
in this city.
This is true of me, as well.
Can you speak about sort o
what you saw
and what led you to write
this op-ed
about how we're valuing one
little bit more than the other
-Yes. I mean, it was kind of
a staggering thing.
I had both of these two
phone calls in one day.
And the first
was with the production
that I'm going to start shooting
at the end of the month
and all the precautions
that were being taken.
And the second
was with my son's school
to hear about what precautions
were being taken there.
And just the contrast
could've not been more stark
In our production,
they had an industrial hygienist
walk through all the sets.
And they were reconfigured
and there were air purifiers
And the ventilation system
was redone.
An entire department was created
for COVID safety.
In my son's school,
which is not particular to him
but to all the schools
across the city,
I heard about how airflow
was being gauged
by a piece of toilet paper
attached with a paper clip
to a yardstick.
You know, in our production,
you get tested
before you start work.
Our crew is tested
one to three times a week.
Actors are tested every day.
People entering
my son's school building,
whether they choose to be tested
before they started work
was optional.
And then people
entering the building
once school officially begin
with kids,
even temperature taking
is optional.
So the result is that even
people who chose to be tested,
by the time they got
the results back,
they had already started work,
and we have 55 schools
and counting
in which at least one person
is infected,
and they have now been exposed
to many other people
in that building.
I mean, I could talk about thi
for a very long time.
But I just keep
having this thought,
which is that
starting on Monday,
the only restaurant you ca
eat at indoors with a mask off
is going to be a New York City
public classroom.
-It was a really nice piec
to have written
insofar that it brought
so much attention to that,
because it is shocking
when you realize
how we are able to do it
when we want to,
and then we just make
very selective choices
of where we want to.
I also want to ask
about "Ratched."
This is the first -- I guess
the first show you signed up for
after the election.
This is a prequel to "One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest,"
the famous Nurse Ratched
from that.
But, yeah, I would argue you d
not need to have seen the film
or read the book to be abl
to enjoy this
as a freestanding show.
-Absolutely not.
And it's a Ryan Murphy
production,
which means that the actor
and the actresses in particula
are amazing and very varied.
It's Sharon Stone
and Sarah Paulson and me
and Sophie Okonedo
and Amanda Plummer.
And the list just goes on
and on and on.
And I get to play
Sarah Paulson's love interest.
And it is not very often tha
you get even one queer woman
playing a queer character.
But to have two queer wome
playing two queer characters
who are romantically involve
with each other
just almost never happens.
-Well, it's one of the man
great things about the show.
And it truly is
an incredible cast.
And it's always great to see you
on-screen again.
And thank you so much
for being here, Cynthia.
It's always a pleasure.
-Thank you.
Pleasure for me, too.